une plante médicinale est une plante
utilisée pour ses vertus thérapeutiques
elle possède donc des propriétés
bénéfiques pour la santé humaine
à la réunion les géraniums rosa est
connu pour ses nombreuses applications
sont en huiles essentielles est utilisée
par les plus grands parfumeurs du monde
mais ce pélargonium qui révèle au
toucher un parfum délicat de rose est
riche d'autres vertus qu'elle adore la
petite france dans les années 60
d'uranium n'a fini presque dans les eaux
mais pas tout à fait génie parfois me
contre aux plantes aromatiques en place
un petit peu sur le terrain et
l'intérieur donc l'uranium pourquoi un
géranium parce que plein de vers tissu
est l'objet depuis 97 relance à mafate
d'uranium et m'a appris que en faisant
des géraniums beau pub on peut d
affaires sur l'utilisation de l'huile
essentielle que ce qui se faisait pas
avant
ses vertus m'a dit peut-être deux trois
petits points ou c'est que c'est
intéressant tout le monde connais tu
vois les essayent soulage azote
rapidement pour malo d'en prendre un
petit peu de géraniums ici sur la joue
cet adam et les carriers un petit point
j'ai un coup de pied sur la dent on va
voir ses impeccables
c'est vraiment rapide et très très très
efficace en peu de temps
mais la feuille aussi de manifestants
avec voilà une feuille de petites
feuilles comme ça pour un litre d'eau 3
ti feuilles pour un bon litre dehors en
infusion bonne une bonne petite tisane
pour la grippe
sinon l'huile de géranium une fois
distillée à distillation fait lui le
géranium les
connue ici pour les marmailles canal
vers les marmailles que nana problèmes
de
vers les parents est donné dans le temps
un goût depuis l'essentiel géraniums sur
un sucre ou bien d'un petit cul ya de
miel pour les verts et c'était la tisane
connu dans le temps lontan
mais aujourd'hui moi personnellement me
l'apprendre utiliser autrement et moi la
remarque et moi l'ami apprécier ses
vertus parce que les un bon pellegatti
vraiment lui l'essentiel géraniums les
sans uranium pour les problèmes de peau
impeccable pour les problèmes de
e
grippe utilisa lit aussi dans une petite
tisane avec du miel toujours avec du
miel en interne jamais prendre lui tout
seul toujours guy miel l'huile
essentielle de géranium et efficace sur
les coupures les blessures les brûlures
donc un bon peu d'affaires pour prendre
avec ça et c'est pour ça que c'est pour
moi un peu un plantes magiques avec ses
huiles que les difficiles d'euros 10
pour un produire mais
le clip produire un pilote que les très
très très apprécié et
de moundji apprécié alias petit à fusion
de la panne a aidé à nice nous a bien
mangé rae ne va boire ça juste après
pour bien digérer voilà le petit isard
n'est pas née alice à nice bien mélanger
la peut rajouter un petit peu d'ordre
là-dedans il fera pas de mal voilà il ya
cinq six personnes navarre la dose ou
cinq six personnes doit mettre ça dans
un petit récipient l'impôt versé là
dessus de l'eau que la bourriche de
l'essonne chaude seul bon on va laisser
ça voilà la plante ne commencent à
changer de couleur la voix bien et ça
commence à être parfumée aussi on sent
la bonne tisane les tiges les plus
costauds les plus durs et ça va repartir
les boisons temps nasa veut repartir
d'ici un mois et demi deux mois tu auras
une petite coupe encore à faire ouais
géraniums c'est peut-être assez fort
assez résistante mais on peut ainsi
connaître on perd parce qu'il ya trop de
pluie c'est l'appui la nuit qui fatigue
le géranium donc au moins une
essentielle de géranium la réunion en
autriche en or ici que nous arriverait à
valoriser ce serait vraiment un bon bien
pour les hauts de l'île relancé le
géranium et repartir dans votre
condition